Speaker 1: Ladies and gentlemen, I have a
momentous bit of news for all of you.
I know I hope everybody is sitting down because
there is something that happened last night
on the Tucker Carlson program that has absolutely
rocked the Republican primary and is completely
changing the dynamics.
Vivek Ramaswamy has announced that he is entering
the Republican primary.
I know, I know.
I'm giving everybody time to react to this.
No one cares.
And it's really, really even Tucker Carlson
kind of seems not to care.
It's it's kind of sad, to be honest.
Vivek Ramaswamy is it?
This is so stupid.
He's an anti-woke entrepreneur and he founded
last year something called Strive Asset Management.
It's an asset management firm, which on its
websites, on its website, says it seeks to
restore the voices of everyday citizens.
Oh, okay.
That sounds pretty, pretty cool.
So anyway, here he is.
And it's just like a deflated balloon.
Take a look at this on, you know, just a cable
host.
But this is a perfect illustration of where
identity politics wind up, right when you
stray from the universal principles that bind
us all under the same rules.
Speaker 3: Exactly.
I mean, we are in the middle of this national
identity crisis, Tucker, where we have celebrated
our diversity and our differences for so long.
Yeah, we forgot all of the ways.
We're really just the same as Americans, bound
by a common set of ideals that set this nation
into motion 250 years ago.
Whoa.
And that's why I'm proud to say tonight that
I am running for United States president.
Wow.
Those ideals in this country, those basic
rules of the road meritocracy, the idea that
you get ahead in this country, not on the
color of your skin, but in the content of
your character, Right.
That you are allowed to speak freely.
Yes.
To be wrong sometimes, as long as your neighbor
gets the same courtesy in return that the
people who we elect to run the government,
by the way, are the people who actually run
the government.
Basic rules of the road.
These are the things that bind us together.
You and I have different shades of melanin.
You know what I say.
So what?
Speaker 1: You know, I could have sworn that
he said different shades of shades of melon.
Like, you know, Tucker is more of a honeydew
guy, whereas Vivek is really preferential
to cantaloupe.
But I think what he's saying is different
shades of melanin, right?
Like different skin color.
Speaker 3: That's not beautiful.
That is not our strength.
Our diversity is meaningless if there's nothing
greater that binds us together across that
diversity.
Yeah.
And the reason that I'm running for president
is to revive those ideals.
And I believe deep in my bones, they still
exist, that most Americans still believe in
them.
But we need to rediscover that.
And the only way we can do it is by start
to talking openly, start talking openly again.
So I'm not going.
Speaker 1: To ask it.
Yeah.
Really a momentous thing.
And then on Twitter, Vivek Ramaswamy announced
he will end affirmative action, tweeting,
quote, As US president, as US president, I
will end federally mandated affirmative action,
full stop.
I will repeal Lyndon Johnson's Executive Order
11 to 46, which mandates race based quotas.
Every Republican since Johnson had the opportunity
to do it.
I'll do it on day one without apology.
Well, he won't do it and it won't be day one.
There will be no day one.
And there is just something funny about, you
know, in particular, like when somebody like
this announces, do you think they know that
this is a joke or do they actually sit somewhere
and go, You never know.
I might be able to pull this thing out.
I'm just not sure.
But a very, very big get, as you can see for
Tucker Carlson getting this announcement on
his program.
And this certainly we will have to spend some
serious time figuring out how this announcement
from RAMASWAMY is going to completely upend
the dynamics of the Republican primary.
So stay with us for more on that.
Maybe someday if it becomes a real thing.
We're going to take a quick break and much
more to discuss.
I'm very much glad you're with us today.